et on parle souvent des pieds dans cette
émission bien entendu des pieds nous on
aime raymond raymond notre chroniqueur
on aimerait monde aime raymond qui pue
des pieds
1 combien de fois on l'a dit ça qu'on
aime le vélo raymond qui pue des pieds
ce soir on a avec nous un ami qui
s'appelle eric du fail c'est ça et du
frais du fait exactement eric du fait
c'est alors du frais du frais et ben
vous êtes très frais que vous êtes très
très bien eric du frais c'est très
simple il paraît que vous êtes vous êtes
quoi vous êtes un évaluateur olfactif
évaluateurs of actif donc c'est très
simple donc en fait vous pouvez évaluer
l'odeur donc des personnes d'accord très
bien alors moi je ne sais pas qui sont
derrière ses pieds puisque c'est tous
les chroniqueurs qui ont sorti leurs
pieds et on va essayer donc de vous à
les évaluer
donc olfactivement les pieds de chacun
des chroniqueurs c'est ça c'est ça
exane d'accord alors la guerre des notes
c'est pourquoi alors là c'est pour leur
attribuer une note de 1 à 7
donc donc racheté quoi voilà en sachant
que 1 c'est très bien d'accord donc 1
500 pour salah et à partir du 7 c'est
que nous on est quand même sur les
odeurs un peu particulière
l'accord très bien donc si c'est votre
métier c'est mon métier j'en ai encore
preuve en est du du café el gringo non
le café c'est très important
en fait ça permet de neutraliser les
odeurs adacore de repartir à zéro si
vous voulez à est comme le vin qu'on
devra on recrache le vin la cavaille
pour ne plus avoir le goût du vin dans
la bouche mais là c'est pareil
ok là on est sur le café comme ça c'est
très fort ça élimine tous très bien
alors on y va
premiers chroniqueurs on découvrira deux
cas il s'agit ensuite alors donc je
commence par les maris par une part
lancôme roule très bien alors chose très
importante
j'allais oublier le tube pour éviter les
interférences sur le dos d'un d'accord
de bontin est magnifique donc là vous
sentez non santé mais pas des billets du
lait d'amande
je sens le lait d'amande on doit laisser
voilà c'est le monde accèdent à
bouchelaghem août atteint alors c'est
quoi la lâcherait sur dîner d'un monde
assez doux ouais ce sens passé ceron
ceron c'est bien ça oui c'est bien c'est
rassurant donc on vient vous mettriez au
je vous mettrais un c1 c'est parfait et
ouais je pense que je mettrais un pour
commencer c'est beau des odeurs mais ce
qu'on appelle le pied parfait deuxième
biais d'un gros sa maman apparemment ce
qu'un homme
alors si vous le permettez je vais
revenir au café à d'accord et oui faut
neutraliser l'odeur d'accord donc on
notera lise l'odeur des charges
d'accord vous allez faire à oued accord
il est bon que la fin il est calé
bordeaux cap et il est bon de café alors
allez-y à l'immersion en tout cas d'être
là monsieur du frère je vous en prie
d'être très frais
alors comment il fait maintenant c'est
rien ça c'est pas mal ça donc là c'est
python ouais abbas assure il ya du
piment du là il ya du caractère harissa
ya d'arrêt ça sur les p o mais attention
quand je lis piment on est dans le bon
sens du terme
d'accord on est dedans on est dans la
cie du lait on est là c'est pas mal ok
c'est pas mal ça peut être un bon parfum
de femme
effectivement comme vous mettez là de
notes alors du coup moi je viens de
faire des jaloux c'est mieux on s'est
moins bien c'est moi bien bas là on est
sur deux produits différents on essaye
alors de la fin c'est compliqué vous
accorder sur des produits différents
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal moi je
mettrais je mettrais je me ferais un
aussi un aussi bon bah bravo alors
regardé c'était valérie bénaïm
pauli attention là là ça se corse
alors ça passe maintenant aller il va
repasser au café vous savez qu'on a à
prendre ou à laisser après je pense
qu'on va pas tous les faire quoi que
c'est sympa alors je sais pas qui sont
ces pieds là oui ils sont très beaux
bravo c'est qui ça à oui on en a mis les
pieds là c'est à vous habille cela on va
faire cela très bien on va faire cela
très vite là il ya une série après il
vola à lasson rigoler là on
al'impression extrêmement drôle à l'acd
castrés spéciaux dont ma vie il ya des
pieds l'halloween à lorik donc là on est
là on est sur ces boisés musc ambré
ouais voilà ouais c'est la forêt c'est
vrai mais la forêt est intéressant et la
forêt non non c'est la vraie forêt la
nature comme ça pas mal mais j'ai
commencé bien c'est très intéressant
on est d'abord là on serait plutôt on
irait plutôt sur un parfum homme c'est
un homme ça on sera sûr à parfum homme
si je devais accord jusqu'au bout de la
démarche ont valu aux innovateurs se
voit là bas parce que là ils sont
vraiment là il ya vraiment des pieds ce
qu'on appel du pied dégueulasse alors
venez voir là là c'est l'ail et là c'est
une horreur
là on enchaîne là là c'est allé là il
faut très très mal ah non mais là je
rigolais la dalle et dollars voilà la
côte est de la côte et j'ai testé maxima
maxim maksimov force qui a pas de
problème maxime salue parce que là là là
c'est sans quoi la non ça se trompe je
ça sent la cannelle dans la cannelle la
chamelle du temps c'est le christ et ses
bijoux ses péchés mais c'est pas des
piétons non c'est sûr enfin c'est mon
travail us
5e les eaux les limites mais ça passe
c'est sympa ça débite mais sa part oui
non non c'est bel et bien quelque chose
c'était intéressant à bcg caveau j'étais
même pas que c'était vous carreau
comment ça va car au salaire pas de
soucis à tout va bien j'ai dit mais ça
paraît alors l'art là je vais disent les
pieds pour ceux qui connaissent il ya et
un gâteau tu n'as qui s'appelle le
boulot sur maman dirigeait et que si ça
mais quelle horreur me replonger une
nouvelle fois prendre du plaisir et du
café faut pas en abuser non plus allez
allez vous asseoir carreaux envers si
c'est tout ça alors vas-y jean-mi
allégeant mime et à des très très gros
pibre bas se sécher jean vidal alors on
va pas se tromper il a des pieds mon
corps il ya un an ne peut pas faire elle
peut faire une seule attaque judas me
suis lauréat peut pas tout faire je fais
ring et dawid ans et là c'est quoi ton
et twitter pour là c'est corsé du désert
non mais là c'est là c'est du lourd
ah ouais là c'est du lourd pour elle
défense et laisse pas comme ça je sais
bête quoi lasser betts et voilà c'est
l'odeur d'une bête c'est assez fongiques
donc oui à dieu a dû chanter enfin on
est sur un mélange de de champignons de
cabourg
un cc sort fait pas enfin c'est disons
que c'est dégueulasse c'est pas ça non
utilisés rejeté savons pas non plus dire
que c'est catastrophique
c'est rejeter des bras face on va pas se
mentir
oh là là normalement oui oui son surnom
dans le métier c'est les pieds qui fut
donc voilà donc on lève quand il a été
nommé influence à vous monsieur avait-il
réagi le joueur de du dinamo zagreb ou
fongiques et s'est évanoui là sergei
fondu mais c'est du haut niveau là sûr
que non je vous jure que non pourquoi ça
n'a pas vraiment fait quoi il ya même
des mousses si j'ose dire qu'à une bête
était balle assez clairement c'est pas
c'est papa c'est quoi ressentir que je
vous êtes sûr bah non je n'en fais pas
moi c'est vraiment wayne on l'a en fait
on transperce barque et la personne mais
c'est normal
footballeur vous connaissez rien
qu'est ce qui s'est passé là c'est très
agressif le jojo dubarbier magnifique 44
au regard des moyens donnés alors c'est
agressif et c'est très spécial ici ou là
versé très agressif et c'est totalement
inexploitable en soi même pour un homme
mais quand même des footballeurs des
rugbymans vraiment des gens viril c'est
maxime est ce c'est pas possible
d'accord merci donc voilà donc vous
n'avez pas ils vous avez payé allant sur
la prod
non mais elle sa ford ont encore une
fois c'est pas je veux dire pas contre
vous c'est vrai pas voilà pourquoi pas
ce que c'est les cabanes de sofiène ben
non c'est franchement arrêtez c'est un
battant et l'histoire 40 a confiance de
plaimont il a été super honnête il a dit
qu'il avait peur mais c'est sûr quand
même depuis tôt ce matin chaussées
malienne et où il a joué dans bien des
gens me
[Rires]
bernard voulait me berna touche pas les
champs touchera parce que c'est notre
salle peu dangereux non mais c'est naze
en carreaux honnêtement ouais ouais
c'est là la principale défendu bernard
et égoïste c'est tout ce papier je te
montre sonnette bernard sonnette modem
dallas et monsieur est honnête quand
même dix ans à zaragoza plus bas à
monsieur du frais